Algo en lo que siempre estoy pensando
es en el tema de esta sesión, la simplicidad.
Y estoy tentada a llamarlo simplón
pero en el mejor sentido de la palabra.
Estoy tratando de descifrar dos cosas muy simples:
cómo vivir y cómo morir, punto.
Es lo único que trato de hacer, todo el día.
Y también trato de hacer las tres comidas y darme una que otra merienda
y, bueno, gritarle a mis hijos y hacer todas las cosas normales
que te mantienen con los pies en la tierra.
Así que tuve la gran fortuna de haber nacido soñadora
Mi hermana mayor estaba ocupada torturando a mis padres,
y ellos estaban ocupados torturándola a ella.
Así que tuve la suerte de que me ignoraran por completo--
lo cual es fabuloso, déjenme decirles.
Así que toda la vida tuve la oportunidad de andar soñando despierta todo el tiempo.
y finalmente soñe que entraba a NYU en una muy buena época--en 1967,
donde conocí un hombre que trataba de explotar el edificio de matemáticas de NYU.
y yo me pasaba escribiendo horribles poesías y tejiéndole jerseys.
las feministas nos odiaban, y todo era horrible
de principio a fin.
Pero yo seguí escribiendo mala poesía, y él no hizo explotar el edificio de matemáticas,
pero se fue a Cuba.
Pero yo le dí el dinero porque yo era de Riverdale
así que tenía más dinero que él.
(Risas)
y era una buena forma de ayudar, ya sabes, a la causa.
Pero cuando el regresó, y las cosas sucedieron,
y decidí que realmente odiaba lo que escribía
y que era prosa terrible, terrible y recargada.
y decidí que quería contar,
que quería contar una historia narrativa
y que aún quería contar mis historias.
Así que decidí que iba a empezar a dibujar. ¿Qué tan difícil podía ser?
Entonces lo que pasó es que empecé
a convertirme en una ilustradora de editoriales, por pura, ya sabes,
pura lo que sea, pura ignorancia.
Y empezamos con un estudio --
bueno, Tibor empezó un estudio, llamado M & Compañía.
Y la premisa de M & Compañía era , no sabemos nada
pero no importa, lo vamos a hacer de todas maneras.
Y de hecho, lo mejor es no saber nada,
porque si sabes demasiado te bloqueas.
Entonces, la premisa en nuestro estudio era,
que no hay límites, no hay miedo.
Y yo-- mi trabajo de tiempo completo, encontré el mejor trabajo del mundo,
que es soñar despierta e inventar ideas absurdas
por suerte había suficiente gente ahí --
y era un equipo, y era colectivo,
no era yo sola inventado ideas locas.
Pero el asunto es que yo estaba ahí, como yo misma, como una soñadora.
Y algunas de las cosas-- digo, la historia de M & Compañía es una larga historia,
y evidentemente necesitábamos ganar algo de dinero,
así que decidimos crear una serie de productos.
Y algunos de estos relojes,
tratando de hacerlos lindos y divertidos--
tal vez no sólo intentándolo, esperemos que tambien lográndolo --
y poder hablar acerca de contenido,
para romper con las expectativas, usar humor y sorpresa,
elegancia y humanidad en el trabajo era realmente importante para nosotros.
Era muy importante, era una época muy impersonal en materia de diseño
y lo que queríamos decir es que el contenido era lo importante,
no el empaque, no el forro.
Hay que ser periodistas e inventores
hay que usar la imaginación más que ninguna otra cosa.
Pero lo bueno es que tengo un perro
y, aunque no sé si creo en la suerte --
en realidad no sé en que creo, es un asunto complicado --
pero si sé que antes de irme, le agito su cola siete veces.
Entonces, cada vez que el vé una valija en la casa,
porque, saben, todo el mundo siempre está de salida,
y siempre están agitándole la cola a este maravilloso perro,
y él sale corriendo a la otra habitación.
Pero yo puedo hacer la transición de trabajar para niños y--
y de trabajar para adultos a trabajar para niños en las dos direcciones
porque, saben, puedo decir que soy immadura
y de alguna manera es cierto.
En realidad-- quiero decir, podría decirles que no he entendido --
no estoy orgullosa de eso, pero no he entendido
digamos que 95 por ciento de las charlas de esta conferencia.
Pero en cambio he estado tomando lindas notas en forma de dibujos
y tengo una cebolla maravillosa de la charla de Murray Gell-Mann.
Y una página de lindos garabatos de la charla de Jonathan Woodham.
Así que del no entender salen cosas buenas --
(Risas)
-- de la cual haré un cuadro y luego terminará en mi trabajo.
Entonces, yo estoy abierta a las posibilidades de no saber nada
y de descubrir cosas nuevas.
Entonces, respecto a escribir para niños, parece algo simple, y lo es.
Se tiene que condensar la historia en 32 páginas, generalmente.
y lo que realmente tienes que hacer es acortar lo que quieres decir.
y se espera que no les hables a los niños con aires de superioridad
o que no les hables de tal manera que,
sabes, que no pudieran soportar leerlo más de una vez.
Así que espero estar escribiendo,
libros que sean buenos para niños y para adultos.
Pero las ilustraciones reflejan,
Creo que yo no pienso diferente para niños que como pienso para adultos.
Trato de usar el mismo tipo de imaginación, el mismo tipo de humor,
el mismo tipo de amor por el lenguaje.
Bueno, yo tengo muchos amigos bien parecidos.
Este es Andrew Gatz, y entró por la puerta y le dije,
"Tu, siéntate ahí", saben, yo tomo muchas fotos.
Y la silla Bertoia en el fondo es mi silla favorita.
Así que logro meter todas las cosas que me gustan,
y ojalá que ocurra un diálogo entre adultos y niños a muchos niveles diferentes,
y espero que diferentes, diferentes tipos de humor evolucionen.
Y los libros son realmente diarios de mi vida.
Yo nunca-- A mi no me gusta las tramas.
No sé lo que quieren decir las tramas.
No soporto la idea de algo que empiece por el principio,
sabes, principio, medio y final, eso realmente me asusta,
porque mi vida es demasiado aleatoria y confusa,
y yo la disfruto así.
Pero bueno, entonces una vez yo estaba, estábamos, en Venecia.
y esta es nuestra habitacion, y tuve este sueño
que llevaba este fantástico vestido verde,
y yo miraba por la ventana
y fue algo realmente hermoso.
Y entonces logré poner eso en esta historia, que es un alfabeto,
y espero continuar en algo más.
La letra C tenía otras cosas.
También tuve mucha suerte al conocer al hombre que está sentado en la cama,
aunque en el dibujo le puse pelo, en realidad el no lo tiene --
bueno, tiene un poco, o bueno, solía tener pelo.
Y con el logré realizar un proyecto que fue realmente fantástico.
Yo trabajo para la revista New Yorker, y hago portadas, y sucedió el 9/11
y eso fue, saben, total y completamente el fin del mundo cuando lo supimos.
y Rick y yo íbamos a una fiesta en el Bronx,
y alguien dijo Bronxistan,
y alguien dijo Fareeristan.
y se nos ocurrió esta portada para el New Yorker,
lo cual logramos -- no sabíamos bien lo que estábamos haciendo,
no estábamos intentando ser chistosos, no lo estábamos intentando
bueno, no es cierto, en realidad si estábamos intentando ser chistosos.
Esperábamos ser chistosos, pero no sabíamos que iba a ser una portada,
y no sabíamos que esa imagen, en el momento que éso sucedió,
iba a ser algo tan maravilloso para tanta gente.
Y en realidad se transformó en el --no sé,
en uno de esos momentos en el cual la gente se empieza a reir acerca de lo que está sucediendo.
y desde, ya sabes, desde Fattushis, a Taxistan, a,
los Fashtoonks, Botoxia, Pashmina, Khlintunesia, y así sucesivamente,
logramos tomar la ciudad
y reirnos de esto tan extraño. ¿Quiénes son? ¿Qué está pasando aqui?
¿Quiénes son éstos? ¿Quiénes son estas tribus?
Y David Remnick, quien fue realmente maravilloso en esto,
tenía un conflicto: a él no le gustaba Al Zheimer, los Al Zheimers,
porque pensó que iba a ser un insulto para la gente con Alzheimer.
Pero entonces pensamos "David, ¿quien se va a dar cuenta?
Ellos no van a darse cuenta.
(Risas)
Entonces lo dejaron en la portada, lo cual fue algo bueno.
Saben, en el transcurso de mi vida yo nunca sé lo que va a pasar
y eso es lo lindo del asunto.
Una vez estabamos en Cape Cod, claramente un sitio de mucha inspiración,
y compré este libro que se titula en inglés "Los Elementos del Estilo" en una venta de garage
y yo no -- yo nunca lo usé en mis estudios,
porque estaba muy ocupada escribiendo poemas y perdiendo las asignaturas
y no sé que más, sentada en los cafés.
Pero tomé el libro y empecé a leerlo y pensé, este libro es asombroso.
Y pensé -- la gente tiene que enterarse de que este libro existe.
(Risas)
Entonces decidí que necesitaba unas cuantas mejoras, algunas ilustraciones.
Y básicamente, llamé a, bueno, convencí a los herederos de White,
y qué intersección, ya saben
de judía polaca, con familia blanca, anglosajona y protestante y estoy diciéndoles que
Me gustaría hacerle algo a este libro.
Y ellos dijeron que sí, y me dejaron hacer lo que quisiera,
lo cual fue hermoso, maravilloso.
Y entonces tomé los ejemplos que ellos dan en el libro,
y simplemente hice 56 ilustraciones, básicamente eso fue lo que hice.
Bueno, este es, no sé si pueden leer ésto.
"Bueno Susan, estás en menudo lio"
y cuando se trata de gramática,
la cual, como saben, es increiblemente árida.
E.B White escribió de una manera tan maravillosa y chistosa-- y Strunk también--
y cuando llegas a la normas y , ya sabes,
hay tantos asuntos de gramática --"¿te importa si te hago una pregunta?
¿Te importa el que yo haga una pregunta?"
habría, podría, debería, or habría, debería, podría'
y "habría" es el amante de Coco Chanel y "debería" es Edith Sitwell,
y "podría" es un sujeto de August Sander.
y "se percató de una gran mancha en el centro de la alfombra"
(Risas)
Así que hay un tono de eufemismo británico, como de asesinato y misterio
que en realidad me encanta.
y luego, "Sé claramente oscuro! Dale a tu salvajismo una forma que podamos entender."
E.B White nos escribió una serie de reglas,
que te pueden paralizar o hacer que lo odies
por el resto de tu vida, o las puedes pasar por alto, que es lo que yo hago,
o puedes, no sé, comerte un emparedado
Entonces lo que hice cuando estaba pintando es que empecé a cantar,
Porque en realidad me encanta cantar,
y pienso que la música es la forma mas elevada de todas las artes.
Entonces le encargué al maravilloso compositor, Nico Muhly,
quien escribió nueve canciones, usando el texto,
y presentamos una noche fantástica de --
el escribió la música, tanto para aficionados como para profesionales.
Mis instrumentos fueron la taza de té temblorosa y el resorte sin fin
en la sala de lectura principal de la biblioteca pública de Nueva York.
donde se supone que tienes que estar muy, muy callado
y resultó un evento tremendamente maravilloso
el cual esperamos repetir.
¿Quién sabe? El New York Times Select, los editores de opinión,
me pidieron que hiciera una columna, y me dijeron que podía hacer lo que quisiera
así que una vez al mes, durante este año
He estado haciendo una columna llamada Los Principios de la Incertidumbre,
la cual, bueno, yo no sé quien es Heisenberg,
pero puedo mencionarlo como si lo supiera,
los principios de la incertidumbre, así que ya saben.
Voy a leer rápidamente -- y probablemente voy a editar un poco
porque no me queda mucho tiempo-- algunas de las columnas
Así que, básicamente la situación resultó muy entretenida
porque yo decía, "¿Bueno, cuánto espacio tengo?"
Y ellos decían, "Bueno, ya sabes, es la Internet"
Y yo respondía, "Si, pero ¿cuánto espacio tengo?"
Y ellos decían, "Es ilimitado, es ilimitado".
Así que la primera columna fue muy tímida y empezaré.
"Cómo puedo decirles todo lo que hay en mi corazón?"
Imposible empezar. Suficiente. No. Empecemos con el desafortunado dodo".
Y menciono al dodo y hablo de su extinción,
y después hablo acerca de Spinoza
"Mientras que el último dodo moría, Spinoza buscaba una explicación racional para
todo, llamada eudemonia.
Y entonces exhaló por última vez rodeado de sus seres queridos
después de tomar sopa de pollo como su última cena."
Resulta que lo sé a ciencia cierta.
Y despues murió y no hubo más Spinoza, extinto.
Y no tenemos un Spinoza disecado,
aunque el perro de Pavlov si está disecado
y lo visité en el Museo de la Higiene en San Petesburgo, Rusia.
Y ahí está, con esa horrible caja eléctrica en su trasero
en este lugar, fantástico y decrépito
"Y pienso que debe haber sido un día muy, muy oscuro
cuando llegaron los bolcheviques.
A lo mejor se rieron entre ellos,
pero Stalin era un paranoico, aun más que mi padre."
(Risas)
No tienen ni idea.
"Y decidió que su plana mayor tenía que ser extinta".
Creo que eso lo inventé yo, buena cosa.
Así que esta tabla de, saben, es solo una tablita,
porque la tabla de toda la gente que mató sería infinita.
Así como fusilados, golpeados en la cabeza, arrojados.
"La familia de Nabokov se escapó de Rusia. Como puede el joven Nabokov
sentarse inocente y elegantemente en una silla roja,
hojeando un libro y unas mariposas,
imagínense tal desarraigo, tal pérdida".
Y quiero decirles que esto es un mapa.
Así que, "La familia de mi bella madre también se escapó de Rusia,
había demasiados motines.
Dejando atrás la choza, los bosques de moras, los gansos, el rio Sluch,
fueron a Palestina y luego a los Estados Unidos."
Y mi madre me dibujó este mapa de los Estados Unidos de América,
y éste es mi ADN aquí presente, porque esa persona con la que crecí
no le vió utilidad alguna a los hechos, en absoluto.
Hechos que fueron desterrados de nuestro hogar.
Así que, si ven que Texas - ya saben, Texas y California
están debajo de Canadá y que Carolina del Sur está arriba de Carolina del Norte
este es el hogar en el que yo crecí, ¿bueno?
Así que es un milagro que yo esté aquí hoy.
En realidad no lo es, en realidad es una cosa maravillosa.
Pero después ella dice Tel Aviv y Lenin,
que es de donde vienen, y lo siento, el resto no se sabe, gracias.
Pero en su vocabulario,significa lo siento el resto es desconocido
lo siento, el resto no se sabe, vete al infierno,
porque no podía importarle menos.
(Risas)
La imposibilidad de febrero,
es que en realidad febrero en Nueva York es un mes miserable
y para mi evoca imágenes de cosas terribles, en realidad terribles
bueno, no tan terribles.
Recibí una caja en el correo, envuelta en papel periódico
y en el periódico había una foto de un hombre que estaba muerto
Y me dije, "Espero que en realidad no esté muerto,
sino que esté disfrutando la nieve, recostado,
pero el pie de página decía que estaba muerto."
Y de hecho lo estaba, creo que está muerto, aunque yo no lo sé
a lo mejor no está muerto.
"Y esta mujer está agobiada, no por ese hombre,
sino por todas las cosas tristes que suelen suceder en febrero".
Hay consuelo.
Este hombre esta furioso porque alguien arrojó estas cebollas por la escalera,
y básicamente, como ven, creo que las cebollas son un tema común aquí,
y él dice "Es imposible no mentir".
Es febrero y es imposible no mentir."
Y en realidad me paso mucho tiempo preguntándome
¿qué tanta verdad decimos?
¿Qué es lo que en realidad - qué historia estamos contando en realidad?
¿Cómo sabemos cuando somos nosotros mismos?
¿Cómo sabemos, en realidad, que estas frases que salen de nuestras bocas
son historias reales, saben, frases verdaderas?
¿O son frases falsas que creemos que debemos decir?
Voy a pasar por esto rápidamente.
Una cita de Bertrand Russell,
"todas las tareas de todas las épocas, toda devoción, toda inspiración,
todo el resplandor de la plena madurez del genio humano
están condenados a la aniquilación
Asi que si eso es verdad, mis amigos,
y si, es verdad, entonces ¿cuál es el punto?"
Una pregunta complicada.
Así que, saben, hablo con mis amigos
y voy a obras de teatro en las que cantan canciones rusas --
Oh Dios mio, ¿saben que?
Podemos -- no, no tenemos tiempo.
Grabé a mi tía, la grabé cantando una canción rusa de
Saben que, ¿podemos oirla un segundo?
¿La tiene?
(Musica)
OK. Grabé a mi tia, que acostumbraba a nadar en el óceano
todos los días de su vida hasta que cumplió 85.
Y así que, esa es una canción sobre la miseria que nos es común
porque somos de Rusia, ¿ven?
(Risas)
Fui a visitar a Kitty Carlisle Hart, que tiene 96 años.
y cuando le llevé una copia de "Los Elementos del Estilo",
me dijo que la iba a guardar como un tesoro.
Y yo dije, "Oh", y ella mencionó a Moss Hart y yo dije,
sabes, cuando te lo encontraste sabías que él era,
y ella dijo, sabía que era él.
(Risas)
Así que el libro me habría servido mas a mí, pero fue un momento verdaderamente maravilloso.
Además que ella salió con George Gershwin, y después de eso no hay más.
Gershwin murió a la edad de 38.
Está enterrado en el mismo cementerio que mi esposo.
No quiero hablar de eso ahora.
No quiero hablar - lo que le faltaría a ese cementerio para ser perfecto
Es el mausoleo de la familia Barricini, que está cerca.
Creo que la familia Barricini debería abrir una tienda ahí en el mausoleo y vender chocolate.
(Risas)
Y me gustaría administrárselas.
Y fui a visitar a Louis Bourgeoise,
que sigue trabajando, y le dí una mirada a su lavamanos,
que es en realidad asombroso, y me fui.
Y después tomé una foto de un sofá que estaba en la calle y luego pinté un cuadro.
Y una mujer que vive en nuestra calle, Lolita.
Y después voy y me tomo un té.
Y después murió mi tia Frances, y antes de morir
intentó pagar su pan con paquetes de Sweet n' Low.
(Risas)
Y me pregunto cual es el punto y entonces lo sé y veo
que Hy Meyerowitz, el padre de Rick Meyerowitz
un vendedor de artículos para lavado en seco del Bronx
ganó el concurso de dobles de Charlie Chaplin en 1931.
De hecho, ese es Hy.
Y veo un hermoso frutero,
y veo un vestido que cosí para unas amigas mías.
Y dice, Ich habe genug, que es una cantata de Bach,
y antes yo creía que significaba 'He tenido suficiente, no aguanto más,
déjenme en paz, pero estaba equivocada
Significa que tengo suficiente - y eso es absolutamente cierto.
Sucede que estoy viva, fin de la discusión. Gracias.
(Aplausos)